[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
finally enlightenment in its view of the
action of faith finds the rejection of
enjoyment and possessions wrong and
purposeless as to the rejection being
wrong enlightenment is an agreement with
faith on this point for faith itself
acknowledges this reality of possessing
holding on to an enjoying property and
holding on to property its behavior is
all the more self-centered and stubborn
then in its enjoyment it is all the more
crudely self abandoned since its
religious act of giving up possessions
and enjoyment falls on the far side of
this reality and purchased his freedom
for itself on that side this service of
sacrifice of natural impulses and
enjoyments has in fact owing to this
antithesis no truth retention occurs
along with sacrifice the latter is
merely a symbol which performs real
sacrifice on only a small portion and is
therefore in point of fact only a
sacrifice in imagination
in paragraph 569 Hagel now turns to the
Enlightenment stake on the action or the
working the the deed of faith what it is
that the consciousness or you might say
also the community and institution of of
those who are representing and are
motivated by faith what it is that
they're doing and the Enlightenment
makes this critique at many points you
know if you want to look for works in
which this sort of thing is taking place
in early modernity and indeed in the
18th century which is just before Hegel
the century of the Enlightenment also
called the seiected Lumiere right then
you could say look at Hume and his
natural history of religion and the many
discussions of religion or look at the
encyclopedias or look at so many other
authors now what is is being criticized
here is faiths action we've already
looked at how it comports itself you
might say cognitively or intellectually
now we're looking at how it how it does
things practically but also we could say
performative Lee and Hegel tells us
enlightenment is rejecting the rejection
that faith is is proposing and and it's
saying this rejection this sacrifice
this valuation that you're engaging in
Hegel is not using the word asceticism
here but we might think well ahead to
other people who talk about asceticism
it's really without value it doesn't
have the meaning that you're ascribing
to it Oh religious people so he says
enlightenment in its view of the action
of faith finds the rejection of
enjoyment and possessions wrong and
purposeless so it's rejecting it on two
grounds the purpose of nests of it we're
going to see discussed in the next
paragraph
but why is it wrong well you know we can
think of various forms of wrongness
wrongness is sometimes based in an
inadequate or false or selective view on
things sometimes it's about you know
what is morally wrong oftentimes these
to coincide with each other sometimes
it's because of what we might call
hypocrisy which is what the
Enlightenment is actually accusing faith
of at this point so he says as to the
rejection being wrong enlightenment is
in agreement with faith on this point so
once again we see that enlightenment
according to Hegel and I think this is
actually quite true it doesn't work on
its own account simply by erecting an
entire counter narrative and an entire
systematic way of looking at things in
large respect it uses the arms of faith
against it it uses the sincerity that's
involved in religious belief against the
religious believer and thereby develops
something new so he says enlightenment
is an agreement with faith on this point
what is it an agreement about faith
itself acknowledges this reality of
possessing holding on to and enjoying
property now why is faith acknowledging
that well that's an interesting thing to
think about let's put it to you this way
if it's very easy for you to give up
something is that really much of a
sacrifice for you or are you just doing
what comes naturally to you I mean there
are people for example who don't like
the taste of alcoholic drinks don't like
the effect of them upon them and you
know it's not very difficult for them to
abstain from drinking is it you know
another great example when I was in my
you know graduate school days I did
smoke pot a few
and found that you know I actually
preferred drinking and the main reason I
did is because I couldn't stand most of
the people who were smoking pot much of
the time and and I said this is just is
not for me that now is that a big
sacrifice to give that up or are we just
following our our natural preferences if
we're not mortifying ourselves if we're
not engaging in some sort of saying no
some sort of rejection to something that
we actually want we're not really making
a sacrifice and so the religious
believer and you know you think about it
this way Hegel here is talking about
enjoyment and possessions enjoyment of
what we can talk in terms of bodily
pleasures eating drinking you know
religious people fast they refrain from
certain sexual practices including you
know a wider range of partners you know
so there's that elements of it that's
all mortification
but it's only mortification if you
actually do in fact want to eat a bit
more or you know if you do have a libido
that's that's functioning if it's
deadened then it's not much of a
sacrifice for you at all likewise the
possessions right property you know do
you tithe do you do you pay a tax do you
give up something to charity did you
spend alms to the poor you know if it's
not if you don't give until it hurts
then you're not really giving in a way
that matters for faith you could say so
he goes on and he says faith
acknowledges this reality right in
holding on to property he says its
behavior is all the more self-centered
and stubborn and its enjoyment is all
the more cruelly self abandoned since
its religious act of giving up
possessions and enjoyment right this is
canceling them out falls on the far side
of this reality and purchases freedom
for itself on this side so we have to
option
here you can give these things up and
then you purchase a kind of freedom for
yourself now what the nature of that
freedom is that's something that we have
to actually unpack different religious
traditions and even within different
religious traditions different people
construe that in in varying ways but we
also do see religious people who don't
give this stuff up who say you know all
fast but then afterwards I'm gonna stuff
my face and we can come up with all
sorts of other things property was and
possessions was a big one for the
religious orders of Hegel's time many of
which were quite rich and we see this
dynamic playing itself out not only in
Christianity but throughout the world
religions oftentimes the the religious
institutions can be quite secular in
many respects you know we might say this
in our own time in terms of prestige or
social media following or things along
those lines the those who are ascetic
are sometimes not as ascetic as they
seem to be so let's talk now about the
freedom on the other side right he says
this freedom comes through giving up
possessions and enjoyment and it falls
on the far side of reality he says this
service of sacrifice of natural impulses
and enjoyments has in fact owing to this
antithesis this opposition no truth
retention occurs along with sacrifice
the latter is merely a symbol what's
being canceled out is merely a symbol
which performs real sacrifice only on a
small portion so you know if you think
about offerings many religious people do
not engage in tithing 10% of their their
income right which was sort of a
standard back in the day at least within
Christianity and it's interesting
because you know
within religious institutions there
there's often the kind of let's call it
repurposing and reframing that allows
monies to be diverted or properties to
be diverted from one thing to the other
now that's not to say that this is you
know the norm but this is this is a
problem within organizations and and
among some ascetics
it can become a problem for the ordinary
common person engaging in religious
devotions as well you know it's often
the case that rules arise in terms of
you know subordinating property or the
body the externals to the internal and
then people spend all this time and
ingenuity figuring out how to undermine
those rules you know you're not allowed
to use electricity for this or that well
you know maybe batteries are okay you're
not allowed to connect it to this sort
of thing you're not allowed to own this
well we'll find ways around that that's
a problem an Enlightenment rightly
points that out if that happens then he
says you know the the latter the
sacrifice is merely a symbol which only
performs sacrifice on a small portion
and therefore it in point of fact Hegel
concludes is only a sacrifice in
imagination now here he was talking
about the wrongness of you know what it
is that the action of faith is doing now
we need to look at the purpose of this
as regards purposiveness enlightenment
finds it in Neptune possession in order
to know and prove that one is liberated
from all possessions to deny oneself one
enjoyment in order to know and prove
that one is liberated from all enjoyment
faith itself apprehends the absolute
action as a universal action not only is
the action of its absolute being as its
object a universal action for faith but
the individual consciousness too has to
show that it is liberated entirely and
generally from its central nature but
throwing away a single possession or
renouncing a single enjoyment is not
this Universal action and since in the
action the purpose which is a universal
purpose and the performance which is a
single performance would be bound to
present themselves to consciousness as
eat essentially incompatible that action
shows itself to be one in which
consciousness has no part and thus this
kind of action is seen to be really too
naive to be an action at all it is too
naive too fast in order to prove that
one is liberated from the pleasures of
the table too naive to rid the body of
another pleasure as origin did in order
to show that pleasure is finished and
done with the action itself proves to be
an external and single operation but
desire is rooted in wordly and is a
universal it's pleasure disappears
neither with the instrument nor by
abstention from particular pleasures
in paragraph 570 Hegel is now discussing
the purposiveness that's how we're
translating it or Veck Missy kite in
German of the action of the
consciousness of faith the believer the
religious institution here the the
emphasis is placed much more on the
individual of course one thing that we
want to clarify and I've brought this up
at many points in the past is when we
see this this word Beck Messi kite
translated as purposiveness sometimes
that is a great translation at other
times it's leaving a little bit out and
I think this is one of those cases
because you know if we look at the the
lexical level of this term right the the
words that it's composed of Zack goal
and purpose works and that's why we've
got purpose of purpose of Ness and then
Messi cut implies that there is some
sort of measure or if you're like
proportionality going on so when we talk
about something being Zack messag
another way to translate that would be
that it is measured or or proportioned
to the goal to the end to the purpose
that you've got in mind and I think I
kind of is implicit in purposiveness if
you've got some sort of idea about what
it is that you want to accomplish you do
think about the means by which you would
carry that out but this goes a little
bit further I would say and hear the
criticism turns explicitly on that so
what is it that's going on let's let's
look at it from the attitude of what
faith is doing first he says
enlightenment thinks that it's inept to
throw away one possession or to know and
prove that one is liberated from all
possessions it's silly to do this in a
symbolic way you could say to deny
oneself one enjoyment
in order to know and prove that one is
liberated from all enjoyment why why
would you do that sort of thing and you
could say well the Enlightenment you
know attitude only understands is this
sensuous world that we see in front of
ourselves in which case it doesn't make
sense to throw away our enjoyment you
know why should we sacrifice one good
time now for our you know eternal
beatitude or something like that when
nobody knows what the hell that means
well the person of faith does think that
they know what that means they do
believe that like Hegel says that their
action is a universal action and that
they are doing something that is purpose
of in renouncing or sacrificing so he
says faith itself apprehends the
absolute action as universal action how
is it universal by doing something on
one thing which you can perceive in this
case renunciation you are doing
something in terms of all things so
giving up meat you know for particular
days of renunciation or fasting
altogether or you know fasting from one
point in the day to another point in the
day or fasting after you've had your
your meal your one meal of the day and
then you know fasting from noon onward
all these are seen as having a universal
significance and what Hegel is pointing
out here is a problem with this he says
not only is the action of its absolute
being as its object a universal action
for faith but the individual
consciousness too has to show it is
liberated entirely and generally from
its sensual nature so it's in a certain
way participating in the absolute right
and the absolute is engaging in this
action the absolute may have actually
given examples of how to do this you
know you think about Christ as a figure
whose
you know providing an example and
teaching explicitly in Christianity I
think about the Buddha I think about
other figures as well right
so he says throwing away a single
possession or renouncing a single
enjoyment that's not this universal
action it is and it isn't right it's
symbolic of this universal action but it
isn't really the universal action now
Hegel is gonna point something out here
that that's quite interesting and he's
going to give you some examples here so
let's let's go through this he says in
the action the purpose which is
universal purpose and the performance
which is a single performance would be
bound to present themselves to
consciousness as essentially
incompatible the action shows itself to
be one in which consciousness has no
part and thus this kind of action is
really too naive to be an action at all
it can't be purpose of it can't be
tailored to the end in sight by the very
fact of its individuality
it's finiteness it's restricted 'no so
he gives some examples here you know
it's naive too fast in order to prove
that one is liberated from the pleasures
of the table I'm reminded for example of
st. Anselm's discussion of fasting in
the day similar to tinnitus which is not
translated at this point from Latin and
it's directed to monks monks did a lot
of fasting right and Ansem says it's
better off for you and this is roughly
paraphrasing if you become a jerk when
you fast don't fast instead like work on
your terrible temper or your
uncharitable this God will like that
more than you just giving up some food
and then yelling at your fellow brethren
keep it in perspective
make it vac messag right
Anselm might be saying although he's
writing in Latin rather than German and
some would frame this in terms of
prudence which is another way of
understanding
purposiveness
the sense Hinkel also brings up the
example of origin and he says sort of
this is you got to read between the
lines here too naive to rid the body of
another pleasure as Origen did in order
to show that pleasure is finished and
done with
what did Origen do he castrated himself
which was seen as a bad thing by his
fellow Christian theologians and
brethren people are like that is not the
example to follow
mutilating yourself no that's that's not
a good idea but Origen thought well you
know if it can rid me of these problems
and you know you might think about
contemporary examples where people are
struggling with something that they feel
stands in the way of their proper
relationship with the divine and they
deliberately try to cut or burn that out
of their their life now why is this
going to fail Hegel here brings us back
to a fundamental issue consciousness
especially self consciousness is desire
you cannot eliminate desire entirely
from the picture or else you eliminate
consciousness as well and neither can
you even eliminate the pleasures
entirely even if you castrate yourself
or starve yourself or don't listen to
music or you know only wear drab
clothing or pick pick whatever else it
is give up your engagement to your
fiance in order to become a religious
writer as somebody quite influenced by
and also opposed to Hegel will do
several decades later so he says the
action proves to be an external and
single operation all right this is the
sacrifice but desire is rooted in wordly
and as a universal it's pleasure
disappears neither with the instrument
nor by abstention from particular
pleasures Hegel is saying that we have
particular pleasure
which we can give up but we can't give
up pleasure altogether
isn't that an extraordinary thing to say
nor can we give up the desire for it
altogether either
but enlightenment on its side here
isolates the inward the unreal as
opposed to reality just as it held fast
to the externality of the thing as
opposed to the inwardness of faith and
the latter's contemplation and devotion
it places the essential factor in the
intention in the thought and thereby
saves itself the trouble of actually
accomplishing the liberation from
natural aims on the contrary this
inwardness is itself the formal element
which has its filling in the natural
impulses which are justified simply by
the fact that they are in word that they
belong to universal being to nature
here in this short paragraph number 571
Hegel now turns his gaze on to the
Enlightenment and starts out pointing
some of the problems in the
Enlightenment s' own perspective both on
faith and on itself remember that this
entire section which were coming to the
end of was the struggle of enlightenment
with superstition which is what it
construed faith is being and this really
means a struggle of enlightenment not
only with faith as its you might say
twin but also with itself because
there's a sort of superstition that can
come to inhabit enlightenment as well of
which it has to purify itself so Hegel
says enlightenment on its side isolates
the inward the unreal the unity or
Kalika as opposed to reality the veer
Klee kite right we've seen this
opposition coming up many times through
the phenomenology the it the ideal the
inward the intentional as opposed to how
things actually are out there in the
world that has to be in some way
transformed and in many times we see a
you know productive interchange between
these here there's a split that's going
on he says just as it held fast to the
externality of the thing as opposed to
the inwardness of faith in the latter's
contemplation and devotion so
enlightenment he says places the
essential factor in the intention the on
zicht right in the thought thereby saves
itself the trouble of actually
accomplishing the liberation from
natural aims
now why would enlightenment have to
engage in such a liberation from natural
aims natural purposes natural desires
well it's been criticizing faith for
getting that wrong but it also does take
its impetus from faith I mean after all
we don't want to say every single desire
that we have is automatically good as
desire do we
I mean we can go all the way back to
Plato pointing out that desires and
pleasures you know there was a
long-standing sort of argument being
made that Plato is responding to in a
number of dialogues where he says you
know you're saying that any desire or
any pleasure is automatically good well
why do we say some of them are bad then
are we just mistaken
are we off base and saying that some of
them are honorable or dishonorable now
some people did bite the bullet in that
case or you might say sees one of the
horns of a dilemma and say yes as a
matter of fact any pleasure whatsoever
is is good just sometimes people think
they're disgraceful and you can get
derive a certain amount of pain from
that but if they weren't you know
bothering you you wouldn't have a bad
conscience and you'd feel great doing
whatever it is that you want we can
think this out a little bit further and
this is what the in fact did in the
Enlightenment and try to figure out how
we can coordinate our aims and desires
and pleasures that we take so that we're
not interfering with others but that
that implies that not all desires are to
be indulged and in fact some of them are
bad by the way one of the people who
presents this this problem in its
darkest form which is why he received so
much discussion by people examining the
Enlightenment was the mark he decide the
Hegel is not talking about that here but
that gives you a little bit of useful
backdrop I think so it's important that
enlightenment actually does accomplish
the liberation from natural aims even if
it's to return to natural aims there has
to be a certain kind of selectivity so
Hegel says on the contrary this
inwardness the inwardness for for
enlightenment now is itself the formal
element which has its its filling in the
natural impulses which are justified
simply by the fact that they're in word
that they belong to universal being that
is to nature this is not a resolution to
the problem this is a posing of the
problem at enlightenment at this
we should be realizing that it's got
more now that it actually has to sort
out
you